FIRST WE HAD TO SHEPARD SMITH
THE BREAKING NEWS ON THE SCHOOL
SHOOTING IN COLORADO.
>> Shepard: WE NOW KNOW THAT
THERE ARE AT LEAST SEVEN
VICTIMS, POSSIBLY EIGHT AND THAT
THE SCHOOL SHOOTING HAPPENED AT
THE MIDDLE SCHOOL SECTION OF
THIS STEM SCHOOL IN HIGHLANDS
RANCH, COLORADO.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WEREN'T
WITH US EARLIER, ABOUT 1:00 150
LOCAL TIME, MOUNTAIN TIME IN
DENVER.
REPORTS OF SHOTS FIRED AT STEM
SCHOOL IN HIGHLANDS RANCH.
THAT IS SOUTH OF DENVER, PAST
LITTLETON, COLORADO, WERE
COLUMBINE HIGH SCHOOL IS.
THE NEXT COMMUNITY IS HIGHLANDS
RANCH.
THE SHERIFF'S GIVE US AN UPDATE.
THEY ORIGINALLY SAID TWO
VICTIMS.
NOW WE KNOW THERE WERE SEVEN AND
POSSIBLY EIGHT.
HAPPENED IN THE MIDDLE SCHOOL
SECTION OF THE SCHOOL.
IT'S A K-12 PLACE BUT IT WAS IN
THE MIDDLE SCHOOL BUILDING.
TWO JUVENILE SUSPECTS ARE NOW IN
CUSTODY.
THE SHERIFF SAYS THEY ARE BOTH
JUVENILES.
THEY DON'T KNOW THEY ARE
STUDENTS THAT SCHOOL.
TWO ARE IN CUSTODY.
THE SHERIFF HAD REPORTED THEY
WERE LOOKING FOR A POSSIBLE
THIRD SUSPECT.
THEY NO LONGER BELIEVE THERE WAS
A THIRD SUSPECT.
THE SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
REPORTED SHOTS FIRED.
OFFICERS ARRIVED WITHIN MINUTES.
THEY ARE STILL GOING
DOOR-TO-DOOR IN THE SCHOOL.
IT'S SOMEWHAT OF AN ACTIVE
SCENE.
BUT THEY BELIEVE AT LEAST THAT
THE DANGER TO STUDENTS IS PASSE
PASSED.